they want to exterminate Jews and the
black lives matter movement in Chicago
what is stunning to me is that the black
TMZ have we ever played a clip from TMZ
on the show
ever yeah maybe stting with Kanye years
ago TMZ which TMZ is just like this big
gossip rag you you've all seen it in
things over the years it's become like a
a really huge cultural institution well
here is TMZ fully uh doing something
right and true and wow welcome back to
TMZ live um we have to talk about
something that honestly
has uh enraged both of us and I and I
know just from looking online thousands
and thousands of other people uh it is a
reaction to the terrorist attack by
Hamas uh that started on Saturday and
which has now put Israel at War this is
what the black lives matter Chicago
chapter and I want to emphasize that
that is the Chicago chapter um that
posted this yesterday and you saw it
yesterday evening called me because you
couldn't believe what you were seeing
but it is an image of a paraglider with
the Palestinian flag flying off of his
Shute it says underneath it I stand with
Palestine now the caption I think also
Bears because the caption to me is
defiantly saying I know I know what you
your reaction is going to be to this and
the caption says that is all yeah this
is B This is BS so that parir parag
glider by the way the paragliders are
the ones who flew into Israel and they
decapitated babies shot and killed
babies raped women killed women took
hostages slaughtered families in their
homes these are disgusting vile
terrorists that's all they are and that
picture the reason we know about the
paragliders is Hamas they're the ones
that released the video of the gliders
cuz they were so proud of the Carnage
and black lives matter in
Chicago embraced the killing of Jews
they are Hitler hold on they are
hitleresque they are a hitleresque
organization to do something like that
period they these are Nazis essentially
trying to exterminate Jews and they are
embraced by black lives matter in
Chicago it is disgusting yeah the the
the St the statement I stand with
Palestine has nothing to do with those
paragliders nothing paragliders were
terrorists and they wanted the world to
know the terror that they were
unleashing and so why this is
anti-Semitic they want to exterminate
Jews and the black lives matter movement
in Chicago what is stunning to me is
that the black lives matter organization
at on the national level has not
denounce this they have said nothing
because it is damaging it is incredibly
damaging how do you know whatever
credibility and black lives matter has
had its issues over the last few years
um as far as credibility and people
feeling like there were the allegations
of of embezzlement and all of that so
they've had their issues this is a a
death nail to the black lives matter
movement if this is what they're going
to spouse the organization and that the
organization is the National
Organization isn't saying I'm I do not
understand what's his name over at TMZ
what's that guy's name again anyone
remember
like credit where credit is due like I
don't really care about all the gossip
and all the rest of it uh oh Harvey um
Harvey L yeah like good good good good
and
true